uh we're also seeing how these strikes
are developing unions are holding this
country to run some look I don't think
uh it's it's about that and you know
I've done these interviews with you over
a period of time in this now and as this
has grown from from real sector to
postal workers to the NHS and now now
the airports and the Border Force
there's no point in going through
dispute after dispute and blaming the
staff who are going on strike even the
union leaders themselves I saw an
interesting quote from Gary Smith the
leader of the GMB Union uh yesterday
they are being taken aback by the
strength of feeling uh among the
workforce I think there's a bigger
question here how is the government
going to get a grip of uh strikes that
are now in one sector after another that
are going to cause huge inconvenience to
the public and even when we don't have
strikes even when there isn't a strike
day things don't work properly there's
only one of those well in December 12th
of December you know uh you know I
usually have anti-west Coastline
sometimes it's not half the service it
was a few years ago we've got huge
backlogs in the NHS in a e which no
doubt you're reporting the government
faces two big questions how are you
going to resolve these disputes and what
are you going to do to make Britain work
properly again because even when there
isn't strikes
the country's public service that's the
third question as well probably which is
worth the 28 billion going to come from
in order to pay for these pay Rises
where'd you get that figure that's from
the government
uh well it depends I don't know how they
can come up with a figure like that
until we know what the settlement is
ultimately these things will be resolved
around a negotiating table I can't see
right here what the cost would be
because I don't know what the final
salary increase will be so I don't know
how they can come up I'm guessing they
get into that figure it's one that's
been parroted by every government
Minister when they do the rounds over
the last week or so and and I'm guessing
they come to that figure from the
percentage increases that the Universe
are being claimed well look there's
always compromise in the end I've no
doubt the unions are claiming for
whatever percent uh in in particular
sectors and in the end the the
resolution is usually the union has to
accept maybe a bit less than it wanted
and maybe the management has to give a
bit more than they wanted at the start
and then you get to resolve the thing
now the exact meeting point of that has
to be done by the employers and the
unions but the government has to be
focused on this because if they if they
just sit back condemning one set of
workers after another threatening to
bring in new legislation which even
their own transport secretary says would
make no difference to the current
disputes what does that do for the
public it does nothing how's all this
going to end
well I hope it ends with settlements and
if I was in government now if my
colleagues were in government right now
all our energies would be focused on
trying to get settlements to ease the
inconvenience to the public and got a
fair pay increase for those involved at
the moment I see a slight change of tone
from some ministers but I don't see that
effort really happening and actually
what the Prime Minister said prime
minister's questions yesterday is I
think reaching for a legislative
solution that will do nothing to resolve
these disputes do you feel that the
country trees grinding to a hole I think
the government is failing to get a grip
I think there's a lack of grip in
Parliament there's a lack of grip
outside Parliament and as I said a
minute ago one of the things that
worries me is even when we don't have
strikes public services are not working
properly I can scarcely think of a
public service in this country that
works better after 12 years of
conservative government than what before
they come into office that is a damning
indictment of their period of
stewardship you look at one service
after another and that's the case um are
you gonna miss Matt Hancock uh uh I
don't know him personally like these are
personal decisions every time you come
up for it it's another five-year
commitment uh a gather is constituency
Association might have been saying no
anyway so uh look I think maybe if you
sign up for
uh some of these shows you're maybe in
the departure Lounge already